my name is Peter salle ave and i'm the
president of Yale University and I want
to thank everyone for being here it's
great to see students faculty staff and
members of the community gathered
together to recognize veterans day it is
really a privilege to have so many
current and former servicemen and
servicewomen here with us today and I
know I speak for everyone in this room
when I say our deep gratitude goes out
to all of you you bring great honor to
this university in the service of your
country Yale has a proud tradition of
serving those who have served it's
reflected around the plaza which the
weather were better and we were out on
the plaza it's reflected in the names
carved in Memorial Hall just outside
these doors the legacy includes programs
like the warrior scholar project which
supports the transition from military
life to student life it's reflected in
the Yale veterans Network one of our
campus affinity groups for student
faculty and staff it includes the Yale
veterans association which is an
organization of alumni who earlier this
year sponsored a very successful summit
here on campus drew members of the
veteran communities from other iv+
institutions and I felt privileged to be
a part of it it also encompasses the
thriving ROTC presence here at Yale
today last April we marked a milestone
with the very first ROTC presidential
pass in review a ceremony that hadn't
taken place at Yale in more than 40
years and I'm very much looking forward
to the next one it extends to the
individuals all across our campus
reflect a commitment to upholding the
values of this country and of Yale
University and we will hear from a
number of them this morning it's my
pleasure to introduce to you Kim Goff
Cruz yells secretary and vice president
for student life and she will say a few
words about today's program Kim thank
you
Thank You president salivate I I'm
really excited to be joining you and
have feel very privileged to be at a day
to join all of you to celebrate our and
honor our veterans but I want to
especially thank president Sall of a
Provost [ __ ] and Dean Holloway for
joining us here today so welcome
throughout its history Yale has been
home to men and women who have dedicated
their lives to the service of their
countries today we join together to pay
tribute and to reflect on the freedoms
and the privileges that their sacrifices
have made possible we are all honored to
have among us today students faculty and
staff who have served and who are
preparing to serve you will hear today
from a Yale staff member who served in
Vietnam a law school student who served
as an intelligence officer an alum who
has taken an active role in leading Yale
veterans and an emeritus professor and
dean who served in World War two they
represent commitment to honor our
country across multiple generations and
conflicts santo gallicchio toe served in
the united states air force from
nineteen seventy-two threw 1976 as an
air force at air traffic controller he
supported the 1973 arab-israeli war also
known as the yom kippur war he is a
second-generation military and he is
also senior human resource journalists
who serves multiple departments in the
School of Medicine he is an active
member of the university veterans
affinity group and a lifetime member of
the american legion we will also hear
from ashley anderson who is a third-year
yale law school student from Frankfurt
Illinois she received her BS in
political science from the US Air Force
Academy in 2006 and her ma in philosophy
from the University of Texas at Austin
in 2007 Ashley served seven years in the
Air Force as an intelligence officer
during which he was deployed to Iraq and
Kuwait
she is currently providing legal support
to veterans through the veterans legal
services clinic at the law school we
will hear from Tamil Platon who is the
co-founder and the interim president of
the Yale veterans association tom is a
member of the y el class of nineteen
sixty-six while at yale he held a
national in ROTC scholarship and he
received a regular commission in the
Navy in 1967 and served from 1967 to
1971 tom is currently the executive
chairman of mmt inc which is a startup
company that is commercializing
technology developed in yells
engineering laboratories and we will
hear from the Reverend Harry Adams an
alum of Yale College and Yale Divinity
School who is he is an emeritus
professor of the divinity school and he
was the university chaplain the
associate dean of Yale College and the
master of both yes both Trumbo and sabra
colleges he served in world war two as a
member of the US Army Air Forces from
1943 to 1945 and then he returned to
Yale to earn his undergraduate degree as
a member of the class of 45 w each of
our speakers has served and each is now
a valued member of our yell community
they represent all of the veterans who
are here with us today and as you will
hear from Ashley the bomb the bonds of
sisterhood and brotherhood that
transcends all boundaries and enriched
beyond measure our University we are as
a community fortunate not only to have
our treasured veterans but we also have
now firmly established as the president
mentioned within the fabric of our
university culture the cadets and
Midshipmen of our Air Force and Navy
ROTC programs these young women and men
in uniform are a welcome and very common
sight on campus as they move between
classes extracurricular activities
residential colleges and their military
commitments I am happy to see some of
them here with us today and I thank
their leaders including Colonel Phil
and captain Vernon Kemper for the
contributions of these talented students
the ones that they are making to the
ROTC and to yell in general Yale
students yell faculty and staff have
answered the call in times of conflict
and they have also led an advocated for
veterans and other important ways this
afternoon I want you to know that from 2
to 3 30 p.m. the Yale veterans
association will host from rifles two
laptops combat veterans covering
conflicts which will be a panel
discussion at the Whitney Humanities
Center and also throughout the day
students from the de Whitehall Veterans
Committee will place flags on cross
campus and memory of veterans connected
to members of the of the university
community and they will be advocating
for veterans so I hope that you will
take the time to participate in one or
both of these activities a final note
although this is the day that is
designated to honor our veterans they
deserve our recognition and attention
throughout the year I encourage you to
learn more about the yellow ROTC program
the work of a Yale Veterans Association
and the Yale veterans network and to
support military leadership education
and veteran well-being in general in our
community when today has passed and we
return to our busy lives I hope that as
you walk in front of this alumna of the
Alumni war memorial outside and move
through the memorial hall where the
names the classes and the records of
service for our alumni who gave their
lives line the walls that you will take
just a moment to remember the men and
women of Yale who have faithfully taken
their oath to protect and serve and now
it's my pleasure to call upon the
officers of the Yale University Police
Department who serve as our honor guard
so please stand as they offer their
presentation of the colors followed by
the playing of our National Anthem and
then remain standing throughout the
invocation
you
you
I read the following with permission
from Jack beach or a colleague and
fellow fellow veteran grand architect of
the universe called by many names in
many languages by many voices today we
ask that your guiding hands hold us and
all sisters and brothers in military
service near we are grateful for all who
now serve and who have served and for
those in the words of President Abraham
Lincoln gave the last full measure of
devotion in service to their country we
are joined in humility gratitude and our
own measure of devotion knowing that as
we seek to understand an increasingly
complex world we are sheltered by the
vigilant service of citizens to our
Republic we ask special regard for those
who have served but who have not yet
been found and returned home and for
those who have returned but who have yet
to find themselves at home we honor our
military and ask that whatever is
required of them be informed by your
infinite wisdom the light and the truth
as they honorably and loyally seek to
create a peaceful and secure future for
us all please be seated
presidents aliv a secretary golf crews
my fellow veterans active duty military
members cadets midshipman and all
distinguished gets thank you so much for
giving me the opportunity to speak to
you on this incredibly important
celebration of veterans it's an
unbelievable honor and somewhat
overwhelming to speak here today as
representative of veterans not only
because words are completely inadequate
to express the awe and debt of gratitude
I feel at the magnitude of veteran
sacrifices through the ages but also
because while we veterans all share our
service in common we're incredibly
diverse we come from different
generations different Wars different
services different career fields and
incredibly different backgrounds some of
us were drafted some of us volunteered
some saw the military is a calling some
as a necessity and others as a path of
upward mobility we each have unique
complex and complicated views on our
service and our Wars and even with being
defined as veterans I say this to
highlight that the remarks I'm offering
here today are only one small voice
among millions and because I could not
possibly deliver words adequate to the
task of celebrating all veterans I
merely to hope merely hope to share with
you what my service has meant to me and
what it now means to me to be a veteran
one thing I encourage everyone here to
do today and everyday is not only to
express gratitude to veterans and their
families but to listen to to read and to
ask for their stories my own service was
as military service goes relatively safe
and privileged I decided in the wake of
911 to leave a civilian university and
attend the Air Force Academy after four
years there I commissioned and became an
Air Force intelligence officer and I
deployed twice once to support an army
unit in Iraq and another supporting Air
Force aircraft in Kuwait and in my last
two years I had the amazing opportunity
to teach cadets at the Air Force Academy
when I reflect on the meaning of these
years I'd
myself nostalgic for the people that I
came to know and even for some of the
obscure places that I lived I long for a
return to the youthful idealism and
optimism of those days when I first took
the oath to support and defend the
Constitution I missed the sense of
adventure camaraderie and of course
sometimes commiseration that accompanied
intense training and long deployments I
took pride in overcoming challenges and
improving wrong naysayers who thought
that women were not fit for military
service but most of all I treasured
being among the most incredible human
beings people that sacrificed constantly
and without hesitation for the country
and for each other I can truly say that
I knew no better or closer community and
I'm grateful every day that these people
still have my back like many veterans I
found and continue to find meaning in
those that I served with but to say only
this would not do justice to the moral
and emotional complexity that
accompanied that service I saw friends
and fellow service members lose limbs
eyesight and their lives and bear deep
psychological and moral wounds my
friends and I saw families devastated by
the loss of loved ones we fought in wars
whose legitimacy some of us questioned I
served under policies that at the time
forced some of my brothers and sisters
and arms to hide important parts of
their identities I watched us too many
of my fellow veterans and servicemembers
suffered from a lack of access to
essential care and I know that the
sacrifices and challenges of some
generations of veterans before me have
gone underappreciated and disrespected
for too long so while I'm privileged to
look back with nostalgia on my time in
the military for many veterans and for
their families the story is far more
complicated it is one of my most sincere
hopes that as we continue to celebrate
veterans and their families into the
future that we remember and honor our
obligations to those we may have failed
in the past there has truly been no
greater honor in my life than to be
called a veteran and no greater
obligation I often feel unworthy to
count myself in the
last of those that have given so much
those that have seen so much combat that
have sacrificed far far more than me and
many of them are here today I'm
privileged beyond words to count the
most loyal courageous and selfless
people on earth as friends i have found
meaning in the face of uncertainty
through the deep and abiding
relationships that shared military
service builds and I know that I'm
forever obligated to keep the faith with
all veterans to honor them to listen to
their stories to help create opportunity
and to reach out with support and
understanding when needed so in closing
I would just like to add my voice to the
chorus of those expressing love and
gratitude for all veterans and their
families here today to each of you who
have served who have endured and who
have sacrificed thank you from the
absolute bottom of my heart you've made
our country great and you've given my
life meaning I know you don't seek
praise but you deserve it today we
celebrate you happy Veterans Day
you
good afternoon everyone I'm Tamil
Clayton the excuse me president of the
Yale Veterans Association this is a
great great day and a great event I've
seen these events since 2001 and every
year they get better and more inspiring
and today I have the distinct honor and
pleasure to take a moment to recognize
and thank the person who started this
tradition as well as many other
initiatives at Yale that support our
veteran and military community Linda
lorimer initiated in that great we owe
her so much
initiated and sponsored the veterans day
ceremony when she was university
secretary it is one of the many
initiatives that she sponsored to
recognize Yale veterans and yells
history of support for the defense of
our nation she was instrumental in
restoring ROTC to campus and then
supporting its development so that Yale
is now the gold standard for rotc and
the Ivy League and it's so great to see
the cadets in the midshipman here today
with us without her help you guys and
ladies would not be here as officer
responsible for the association of Yale
alumni she supported and encouraged the
formation of the Yale veterans
association and his subsequent
development as the daughter of a career
naval officer Linda understands the
importance and value of military service
and importantly the need for Yale as a
globally important institution to
support and honor it and she has one of
the most satisfying aspects of my
position in the Y VA is receiving
numerous calls for my counterparts at
Harvard and Princeton asking about yells
success in veteran and military affairs
what's going on in New Haven they ask me
well my response is that the success is
due to the strong support of the
administration and we know that Linda is
a major force in that support Linda on
behalf of the veteran military community
at Yale including the Yale veterans
Network the Yale student veterans
council and the Yale Veterans
Association thank you so much for all
you have done for us we would not be
where we are today without you as we say
in the Navy we wish you fair winds and a
following sea as you leave Yale to go to
your next adventure could you come up to
the stage and Fred Nagle come up to the
stage please there is please accept this
small token of our appreciation for all
the big things that you have done for us
and now I would like Fred Nagle the
chairman of the Veterans Association to
present Linda with our gift when that
you've been the most wonderful godmother
imaginable the daughter of a Rear
Admiral who served in three wars was a
strike force commander you simply made
it all happen you clearly have made a
very perceptible change in Yale
University and you just have to walk
around and see all the uniforms and the
fact that service members are now thank
for their service beyond that the L
veterans has done a lot in and outside
the Yale community but you really made
it happen and I think is a further
tribute to what you've done we now have
developed a very close relationship with
West Point there are several graduate
students who are West pointers here
including the president or vice
president of the Yale Veterans
Association and we're going to have our
second Yale veterans summit at West
Point next April and finally maybe
imitation is the greatest form of
flattery I've been asked to start
another shared interest group based on
the success of the Y VA for the
intelligence community but you were the
godmother of it all
okay my dear friends thank you for your
very very kind words but as Tom and both
of you know I am just a representative
of the many who work to have Yale be
much more conspicuously grateful for the
service of its veterans veterans who are
Yale students yell staff yell faculty
and of course our extraordinary alumni
though others of us who have been the
beneficiary of Veterans Service has has
been said already need really to be
saying thank you every day for putting
your lives on the line to defend our
liberties but at least we have this
occasion once a year to offer what is in
our hearts of really praised as well as
Thanksgiving I know that we today those
of us here but elsewhere recognize that
the alums here are just the tip of the
iceberg for those who render service to
our nation from Yale reminded of it in
one way every day going through memorial
chapel I who had a chance for 18 years
to work most directly with our alumni
recognize how pervasive is among our
alumni body as Tom said my dad was a
career naval officer he started his
military career at the end of World War
two serving on a minesweeper he then was
on the involved as a naval aviator
during the Vietnam War and commanded the
largest aircraft carrier in the world at
the time during very tense times in the
Mediterranean in the 70s he would come
home every night and this is not an
exaggeration he loved flying which was
most of his career but he said what
means most is I'm here to sustain the
peace in just a couple of minutes we
will hear what is always one of the high
point of my years the anthems that Tom
Duffy had a range of the all of our
military services and it will be our
chance as each of the representatives
here from each branch lasseur
stanzas recognized to offer our
heartfelt thanks for their service but
for all they represent for other Yale
women and men here and elsewhere but let
me close with a very special salute to
those students in our ROTC units I am so
proud of you and I am so grateful for
your commitment to our country and for
your decision to come to Yale when I was
a student here there were no ROTC units
when I returned to join the
administration in 1978 there were no
ROTC units I said to myself back then
sort of most of your parents were not
even in college then that I hope that I
would stay at Yale long enough to see
rod see welcome back to this campus we
had to wait a long time but it has been
worth it you cadets and Midshipmen are
the shining reasons for why ROTC is so
important to Yale not simply to our
nation I stand a little taller when I
see you walking down Wall Street going
from one class to the other you remind
us of what service means the commitment
you have made at this early age and we
can't wait to wait a couple of years
when you're out of Pensacola or when you
graduated and you're on your own
deployment to see how you are making a
difference in this new way of leadership
that Yale is regaining again as a navy
junior I hope you understand why I say
Anchors Aweigh to you new future
perspectives to veterans that will be
there serving our nation but I conclude
today and saying mostly thank you to the
veterans of today my heartfelt
appreciation for all you do
you
you
you
Oh
let us pray Almighty God as we remember
those who have served their country with
commitment and with courage we give
thanks for their dedication and
sacrifice we pray for your continued
blessing upon our nation and upon all
the nations of our world as we go from
this place of honored memory we beseech
you to bless us that we may strive with
new dedication for peace in our world
and for justice in our common life all
men please remain standing for the
retiring of colors
thank you everyone this concludes our
veterans day ceremony for this year many
thanks to the planning committee into
our ceremony participants and
particularly thank all of you for coming
out to celebrate our veterans today have
a good day